Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Tú y 9 personas
han sido capturados
por superinteligentes
alienígenas supremos,
que creen que los humanos
se ven apetecibles,
pero su civilización les prohíbe comer
seres sumamente lógicos y cooperativos.
Desafortunadamente,
dudan si Uds. califican,
así que deciden
hacerles una prueba.
Mediante su traductor universal,
los alienígenas que
los retienen les dicen:
"Serán formados en una sola fila
viendo al frente por orden de estatura,
tal que cada uno en la fila
pueda ver al frente.
No podrán ver
para atrás o salirse de la fila.
Cada uno tendrá puesto
un sombrero blanco o negro,
asignado aleatoriamente
y no les diré cuántos de cada color.
Cuando diga que empiecen, cada uno
debe adivinar el color de su sombrero
comenzando con la persona que
está atrás y hacia adelante en la fila.
Ni siquiera intenten decir otra palabra
que no sea blanco o negro
o señalizar de otra forma
con la entonación o el volumen;
de inmediato serán devorados.
Si al menos 9 de Uds.
aciertan, se salvarán.
Tienen 5 minutos
para discutir y concebir un plan,
luego serán formados en fila,
se les asignarán sombreros y comenzarán.
¿Pueden pensar en una estrategia
que garantice la salvación de todos?
Pon pausa al video ahora
y resuélvelo tú mismo.
Respuesta en: 3
Respuesta en: 2
Respuesta en: 1
La clave está en
la persona al final de la fila,
que puede ver todos los sombreros y
usar las palabras "blanco" o "negro"
para comunicar información codificada.
Así, ¿qué significado
se puede asignar a esas palabras
que permitan que todos deduzcan
los colores de sus sombreros?
No puede ser el número total
de sombreros blancos o negros.
Existen más de dos posibles valores,
pero lo que tiene dos posibles valores
es la paridad del número,
es decir si es par o impar.
Así la solución es acordar
que quien vaya primero,
por ejemplo, diga "negro" si ve
un número impar de sombreros negros
y "blanco" si ve un número par
de sombreros blancos.
Veamos cómo saldría si el número
de sombreros estuviera distribuido así.
El preso más alto ve
tres sombreros negros frente a él,
así que dice "negro", para decirle
a todos los demás que ve un número impar.
Se equivoca con el color de
su propio sombrero, pero está bien,
dado que en conjunto se permite
que tengan una respuesta mal.
La preso dos también ve un
número impar de sombreros negros,
así que sabe que el suyo es
blanco y responde correctamente.
El prisionero tres ve un número
par de sombreros negros,
así que sabe que su sombrero
es uno de los negros,
que los dos primeros presos vieron.
La presa cuatro oye eso y sabe
que debería buscar un número
impar de sombreros negros,
puesto que uno está detrás de ella.
Pero sólo ve uno, así que deduce
que su sombrero es negro.
Los presos del cinco al nueve cada uno
busca un número impar de sombreros negros
lo que ven, entonces deducen
que sus sombreros son blancos.
Ahora todo se reduce a ti
que estás al frente de la fila.
Si el noveno preso vio un número
impar de sombreros negros,
eso significa una sola cosa.
Verás que esta estrategia funciona para
cualquier posible arreglo de sombreros.
El primer preso tiene una posibilidad del
50 % de contestar mal sobre su sombrero,
pero la información
de paridad que trasmite
permite que todos los demás
adivinen con absoluta certeza.
Cada uno comienza esperando ver
un número par o impar de sombreros
del color específico.
Si lo que cuentan no coincide, significa
que su propio sombrero es de ese color.
Cada vez que esto ocurre,
la siguiente persona en la fila
cambiará la paridad que espera ver.
Eso es todo y son libres de irse.
Parece que estos alienígenas
pasarán hambre
o tendrán que buscar organismos
menos lógicos que raptar.